et c'est ça vraiment toute la force de
ce pixel 3 et de ce pixel 3xl c'est
[Musique]
ça va tu parles comme le temps quelques
heures tu as un bol
tu t'en vas pour charlotte exactement ce
n'est qu'un au revoir autant à new york
vous avez des building et nord otan ça
c'est complètement fondu à un espèce de
château médiéval c'est très bizarre qu
en pense quoi
oui c'est très motivant cette free media
ça qui est vraiment surprenant que vous
avez tous vous avez les petites citerne
là vous retrouvez vous retrouvez des
délais non building et puis les choses
comme ça je regarde les carences du
shérif
[Musique]
bien sûr et mickey
troisième jour new york
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
téléphone que j'utilise depuis quelque
temps c'est le pixel 3 alors j'ai aussi
le pixel 3xl que j'emmène avec moi je
vous parlais du pixel 3 je vais vous
dire pourquoi ce smartphone est
intéressant en quoi google
je dirais pas révolutionne mais se base
sur les usages pour apporter des
solutions pratiques simples complète qui
vont vraiment un contre-courant de ce
qu'on est revenu sur les smartphones
google ne nous parle pas de spec ne nous
parle pas de côté trop technique nous
parle d' usage nous parle de vous de ce
que vous allez pouvoir en faire et ça
c'est pas plus avant dans ce smartphone
et sept points de plus intéressant
regardez moi le temps qui fait
aujourd'hui c'est franchement beaucoup
plus beau qui hier là on voit le haut de
l'empiré state building pourrait presque
voir qu'ils ont garé vais tellement il
fait beau
on est dans un parti sis à greenwich
village pour parler des google puisque
seuls trois ou google pixels 3xl qui
sont juste ici dans ma poche plus petit
modèle plus grand modèle plus petit
modèle que je trouve vraiment plus
pratique parce qu'il est très facile à
manier à une seule main est le plus
grand modèle un peu plus compliqué sur
chacun leurs points positifs que
négatifs personnellement c'est le pixel
trois que je préfère ce qui a souvent
été reproché à ce smartphone et je suis
assez d'accord avec ça c'est que le
design est vraiment old school rien de
bien original sur le grand vous avez
éventuellement l'encoche i mais qui
n'est pas non plus complètement parfaite
c'est vrai que franchement c'est pas
extraordinaire ça casse pas trois pattes
à un canard mais ce qui fait tout
l'intérêt de smartphones c'est pas ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur c'est à
l'intérieur c'est comme la beauté la
plus intéressante c'est celle qui à
l'intérieur voilà je sais je suis
philosophe femme heather moins
intéressante ce smartphone vous n'avez
pas de traces de doigts pour n'avoir
éventuellement sur le haut et sur le
modèle xl c'est exactement la même chose
sur le pixel 3 vous avez un écran de 5,5
pouces et d'un écran amoled avec une
résolution de 2160 par 1080 pixels cdu
fhd plus à 443 pixels par pouce tandis
que sur le xl vous avez les gones al de
6,3 pouces personnellement le pixel ce
que j'aime pas trop
c'est la taille de l'encoche je la
trouve beaucoup trop rendent vraiment
beaucoup trop grande après on arrive un
peu à l'oublier ce que je préfère sur ce
modèle là c'est carrément la supprimer
autant les encoches ça me dérange pas
mais celle là je la trouve vraiment très
très grande c'est depuis plusieurs jours
j'ai mis ma carte sim dans le pixel 3 je
le trouve vraiment mieux ergonomique
très facile à prendre en main il
s'utilise très très facilement avec une
seule main pour moi à choisir entre les
deux smartphones
je préfère franchement la taille de
pixel 3 je trouve beaucoup mieux l'écran
est vraiment parfait si vous voulez
regarder des vidéos sur youtube sur
netflix lorsque vous voulez ça ira très
très bien pour jouer aux jeux vidéo sans
cracher sa voiture de tous les côtés et
en plus ce qui est vraiment bien si vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo qui sont
situés juste à l'avant du smartphone
c'est plus immersif et c'est franchement
bien lorsque vous allez jouer à des jeux
vidéo et les films se rajoutent vraiment
à l'expérience inertie donc ça c'est
super cool
en termes de performance vous avez un
stade rigaud 845 à l'intérieur 4
gigaoctets go ram
on pourrait se dire qu'elle gigoter
drame c'est très peu surtout pour un
smartphone de fin 2018 alors qu'à peine
smartphones qui sont déjà à six huit
voire carrément 10 gigaoctets drame
alors dit j ai opté ram ça pourrait
paraître complètement délirant on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir une fluidité à ce
point sauf peut-être sur quelques
smartphones de gaming et encore par
contre ce qui est vraiment bien avec le
travail qui est fait par google là
dessus c'est qu'à une vraie fluidité qui
est fait avec uniquement 4 gigas de ram
et c'est vraiment tout l'intérêt de ce
smartphone si vous avez une vraie
optimisation logiciel faite par google
que ce soit au niveau la photo au niveau
de la fluidité la navigation est
franchement fluide et applications
s'ouvrent et se ferment très très très
rapidement dès qu'on clique dessus c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux sauf que voilà
google a vraiment fait un excellent
boulot sur ce smartphone il est
extrêmement rapide et extrêmement fluide
il répond très bien aux niveaux et plus
et une adreno 630 vous avez 128 giga de
stockage non extensible
qu'en est-il au niveau de l'autonomie
vous avez sur le seul 3 une batterie de
2009 115 millions paire eur / le pixel
3xl vous avez une batterie de 3430
milliampères heures l'autonomie est pas
complètement dingue c'est pas là où il
va est en tout cas le meilleur
si vous l'utilisez de façon intensive
vous allez le garder une journée au
niveau de l'autonomie
pas plus si vous avez un peu plus
modérément si vous êtes plutôt cool vous
allez le garder une journée demi mais le
garder deux jours ça veut dire qu il
dans votre poche que vous l'utilisez
très peu
quelques appels quelques sms très petit
mail et papus c'est pas le meilleur dans
sa catégorie mais en tout cas on peut
dire qu'il fait le job et parlons
maintenant de la caméra parce que c'est
peut-être le point fort de ce pixel 3 et
du pixel 3xl vous avez si une caméra de
12 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8
vous avez le dual pixels ça marche super
bien et à l'avant je vous montre sur le
modèle xl passé à bien se voir avec ce
soleil à la peut-être là vous avez deux
caméra de 8 mégapixels une grand-angle
et une autre très grand angle l'appareil
photo est très complet vous avez plein
de modes différents brogan mode portrait
mode appareil photo classique de la
vidéo il ya différentes choses qui sont
intéressantes par contre ce qui est
assez cool là dessus
c'est notamment le zoom comme vous avez
ici un seul appareil photo vous n'avez
forcément qu'un zoom numérique néanmoins
le zoom numérique fait franchement bien
le job l'europe je me vient en face le
résultat est assez impressionnant
alors il faut de la lumière
vous avez la lumière ça marche
franchement super bien il ya vraiment un
excellent boulot tu fais là dessus d'un
point de vue logiciel par google parce
qu'il s'agit bien d'un traitement
logiciel vous avez bien évidemment le
mode portrait qui franchement travail
très très très bien a précisé canon afin
de régler 845 et la performance derrière
ça détour super bien de tous les côtés
mais lorsque vous allez complexifier la
scène ça franchement c'est hyper cool
autre mode qui est assez rigolo
vous allez fouiller si vous allez
playground mode vous allez rajouter des
petits personnages en réalité augmentée
par exemple qui va se mettre lui voilà
j'ai mon petit perso en réalité
augmentée je veux pouvoir regarder
autour alors j'ai plein plein de trucs 1
g star wars et marvel il ya plein de
choses ça c'est aussi assez rigolo et un
truc assez marrant au niveau de
l'appareil photo g la fonction motion
active alors ça c'est s'il vous le
montrer c'est plus compliqué à monter
quand on est tout seul
là je fais le point sur ma main est
quand même un bouge le point reste
dessus ça c'est franchement bien lorsque
vous allez filmer quelqu'un il restera
toujours net quel que soit l'endroit où
ils soient et en tout cas ça marche
vraiment bien là dessus il y aussi un
excellent boulot de fait de la part de
google
le son de la vidéo n'est pas parfait
lorsque vous filmez avec la caméra
arrière nettement meilleure lorsque vous
filmez avec la caméra de celle ci pose
je ne rencontre en éditant que j'ai
complètement zappé de vous montrer des
photos prises en conditions de
luminosité normal et en conditions de
faible luminosité
il ya un tout qui complètement ouf c'est
que lorsque vous prenez des photos
puisque j'ai fait de mon téléphone en
condition et les charges en conditions
de faible luminosité plus au début ça
fait une photo c'est assez dégueulasse
et tout de suite vous avez traitement
logiciel qui vient opérer et là vous
avez vraiment la magie qui opère sous
vos yeux et vous avez une image qui est
complètement optimisé alors j'allais
faire un tour dans new york
j'ai fait plein de photos à différents
endroits je vous les montre vous allez
voir c'est hyper le france
[Musique]
l'ol c'est un androïde 9 paille android
stockent 100% pure android
franchement et j'aime beaucoup
l'expérience 100% google là dessus vous
leurs charges et onu à ce décès ou à
vous de poser directement sur son people
stand où vous pouvez recharger
directement son fils ça marche aussi
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 du nfc pour
moi le point le plus important là dessus
c'est que ce smartphone est vraiment
impressionnant on pourrait le comparer à
l'iphone d'un point de vue optimisation
pour en environnement vous avez un os
avec tout environnement complètement
optimisé pour apple
et là vous avez tout l'environnement qui
complètement optimisé pour google
si vous avez un compte youtube deezer
google photos vous avez une boîte gmail
ce smartphone est complètement optimisé
et sera vraiment parfait pour vous ce
smartphone est un parfait l'autonomie
n'est pas génial
le design n'est pas révolutionnaire mais
l'environnement en général pour
l'utilisation est vraiment bien
après vous avez des options de bien-être
numérique qui vont venir vraiment
rajouter à l'expérience
il ya pas mal de petites options
software et c'est ça vraiment toute la
force de ce pixel 3 et de ce pixel 3xl
c'est une machine performante avec un
des derniers soc de qualcomm pas le
dernier tout de suite médaillon de quoi
quand il est sorti le snapdragon 845
vous avez que 4 gigas de ram mais
vraiment optimisé pour moi ce pixel 3
est vraiment un excellent smartphone
maintenant la question c'est doit-on
acheter ce google pixels 3 ou pixel 3xl
alors ça dépend ça dépend vraiment de
vous de votre budget se trouve encore un
peu cher par rapport à ce qu'on peut
trouver à la concurrence néanmoins si
vous trouvez un prix qui est vraiment
très honnête et très intéressant vous
pouvez y aller surtout si vous êtes un
utilisateur des services google parce
que pour le coup c'est complètement
optimiser l'expérience est complètement
folle
en tout cas moi pour utiliser plein de
smartphones je trouve que celui-ci est
vraiment optimisé l'environnement est
génial je vous dis je le comparerais
vraiment un environnement ios c'est pas
la même chose mais en terme d'expérience
pour moi on arrive sur vraiment le même
niveau de qualité et ça c'est vraiment
important amis touristes français je me
trouve devant l'immeuble d'une série pas
si vous connaissez ça si ça vous parle
c'est l'immeuble de la série friends
trouve juste ici à greenwich village
bonjour la tronche de leur sapin de noël
après j'ai après noël et que je vois le
mien je me dis que globalement je pense
qu'on n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes fort
et le meilleur est complètement éclatée
celui là se tient encore si vous à new
york il reste qui est sympa je sors là
j'en mangeais c'est ptet s'appelle
philippe marie félix mairie ici on en
jeu franchement bien c'est pas hyper
cher il ya descendu ces deux trois trucs
set sur un ace aux tweets du coup de
google faisait trouvé ça rapidement pas
on à la caserne de sos fantômes c'est
juste franchement énorme
après fraises après ce second tome il
annote lieu important à faire quand on
est dans le coin tu es le fils de kevin
knight qui est ici je prends le deuxième
méthode et la mixtape pour l'année
dernière quand j'étais passé il y avait
à l'espèce des normes échafaudage bien
dégueulasse devant ils arrivent pas
encore fixée c'était bin ça change
voilà les choses évoluent j'écume
l'année dernière kelly nesat n'est pas
new york
il est en afrique du sud bon voilà
maintenant il est l'heure d'éviter la
vidéo forcément vouloir garder pour vous
serez déjà fessés en ligne mais moi il
me restait ma vidéo édité sur ma chaîne
française sur la chaîne anglaise j'ai
donc deux trois quatre heures encore de
boulot ceci étant dit ça va le faire je
me posais l'ehpad j'ai marché toute la
journée je suis éclaté il est 18h 54
heures de new york et demain matin j'ai
un avion à 9 heures je décolle 6 heures
d'avion direction est las vegas dont je
vous invite à rester connectés parce
qu'on va hausser es on va les voir
toutes les nouveautés tech
ça va être complètement fou rire plein
de choses hyper cool donc fait une seule
chose abonnez vous et n'oubliez pas de
me dire en commentaire tout ce que vous
pensez du google pixels 3 6 et 3 xl si
vous avez des questions de cette
agression de suggestions ou et tous
marqué en bas voilà vous embrasse à
demain pour les soins de bouquins